- [Instructor] What I have here is a line,
and I have a point that
is not on that line,
and my goal is to draw a new line
that goes through this point,
and is perpendicular to my original line.
How do I do that?
Well you might imagine that our compass
will come in handy,
it's been handy before.
And so what I will do is,
I'll pick an arbitrary point
on our original line,
let's say this point right over here.
And then I'll adjust my compass,
so the distance between the pivot point
and my pencil tip,
is the same as the distance
between those two points.
And then I can now use my compass
to trace out an arc of that radius.
So there you go.
Now my next step is to find another point
on my original line
that has the same distance
from that point that is off the line.
And I can do that by centering my compass
on that offline point,
and then drawing another arc.
And I can see very clearly
that this point also has the same distance
from this point up here.
And then I can center my
compass on that point,
and notice I haven't changed the radius
of my compass,
to draw another arc like this,
to draw another arc like this.
And then what I can do is connect
this point and that point,
and it at least looks perpendicular,
but we're going to prove to ourselves
that it is indeed perpendicular
to our original line.
So let me just draw it, so
you have that like that.
So how do we feel good
that this new line that I just drew
is perpendicular to our original one?
Well let's connect the dots
that we made.
So if we connect all the dots
we're going to get a rhombus.
We know that this distance,
this distance is the
same as this distance.
The same as this one right over here,
which is the same as this distance,
so let me make sure I got
my straight edge right.
Same as that distance,
which is the same as this distance,
same as that distance.
And then, so this is a rhombus,
and we know that the diagonals
of a rhombus
intersect at right angles.
So there you have it.
I have drawn a new line
that goes through that offline point,
and is perpendicular to our original line.